So one of the things that worries me,
the noticed,
uh,
in the technology world today is the
degree to which the external world has
view technology with more and more
cynicism and the degree to which,
uh,
you know,
there's a little bit of a backlash
starting.
And I think that there's a few drivers
for that.
I think the recent elections is sort of
one example where people feel that they
were manipulated,
I should say,
by third parties of using technology.
Um,
and I think separate from that,
there's also just the sort of media
waves where,
you know,
uh,
media tends to go in cycles where the
press would build something up and then
tear it down and then build something up
and tear it down.
And I think technology was really built
up in the media for a 20 year period or
so.
And now it's sort of a time of reckoning
and to some extent,
um,
I think that's very unfortunate because
I believe that optimism is a reflexive
asset and sort of the George Soros view
of the world where,
you know,
something that,
uh,
people,
give value to gains value.
Uh,
by that belief in the value of that
thing.
And,
uh,
if you actually look at the major
changes that have happened in the world
is because people have been extremely
optimistic in ways that some folks
thought were,
was irrational.
Um,
but that optimism allowed them to
actually accomplish that giant goal.
I mean,
think of,
uh,
putting somebody on the moon and what we
were able to accomplish in the sixties
or,
uh,
you know,
think about a variety of other examples
like that.
The Manhattan project or you know,
major breakthroughs of all sort of come
through and enormous sense of optimism
and we can do this a manifest destiny
and Sorta,
you know,
the development of the United States as
a country is a good example of that on
the sort of country and governance
level.
Um,
and so one thing that I've seen more and
more increasingly is a increase in
cynicism and people being made fun of
for saying they want to change the world
when they're genuine about it.
And I think that's a very big negative.
And so one of my,
one of the things I've been thinking a
lot about recently is how can you
actually increase the seidel optimism?
What are the mechanisms by which people
can become more enthusiastic about their
future and more enthusiastic about
technology?
Because if you look at the changes that
technology has wrought over the last 20,
30 years,
it literally has lifted tens or hundreds
of millions of people out of poverty.
It has created access to global markets
that has created access to global
information.
Uh,
you know,
everybody's walking around with
literally a super computer in their
pocket that gives them the access to the
sum of all of humanity's knowledge,
uh,
with maybe the exception of scientific
journals which are still blocked.
So I do think that,
um,
people should be incredibly optimistic
about the future.
And one thing I wonder about is how can
you help spread that optimism?
Because I think if people believe they
can do something,
they often achieve things that they
never thought was possible.
So a lot of people have recently had a
lot of very cogent concerns around the
rise of misinformation and
disinformation,
uh,
on social media platforms and how that
impacted our last election.
And you know,
I think those are very legitimate
concerns.
And I think some of the platforms have
made pretty major mistakes in terms of
how they've approached some of those
things.
Um,
it's interesting though because if you
look at it over the arc of history,
uh,
this is not a new story.
Every time that there's a new
technology,
particularly around media,
uh,
there's a set of outcries around how
that media is corrupting culture or how
it's destroying certain aspects of our
life.
And in some cases those are real
concerns.
Um,
there's a great book from Tom standage
about the early telegraph in the 18
hundreds called the Victorian Internet.
And he basically makes the argument that
a lot of the behavior that exists online
today was being done by telegraph
operators in the 18 hundreds because
they were just sitting on these lines
talking with each other over Morse code.
And they would gossip and they would
trade recipes.
And it would date a,
but also it was a way for news to spread
quickly.
And a lot of people argued that it was a
downfall of a variety of things.
It was,
it could be the downfall of markets
cause suddenly markets were more
efficient or it could impact religion or
other things.
And then we had radio actually before
radio,
we had newspapers in the early 19
hundreds and there was the wave of
yellow journalism.
There was a Spanish American war that
was caused by,
by a new form of media.
And then we had radio and radio was
corrupting the youth by spreading rock
and roll and sin and you know,
all sorts of bad things.
And then we had TV,
which was turning everybody into
vegetables.
And then we had,
um,
video games,
which was turning all of our children
into killers.
Uh,
and now we have social media as the next
new media platform.
And instagram is destroying our youth.
And I think that fact about instagram is
true,
but I'm joking about that.
But,
um,
and the broader context,
if you think about it,
every time we have a new form of media,
we make the argument that that form of
media is the thing that's going to
destroy our society.
That's corrupting our politics,
is corrupting our children.
This destroying our ability to think for
ourselves and every time society has
turned out okay.
Now that doesn't mean that social media
platform shouldn't be reacting or
shouldn't be addressing these issues.
I'm just saying,
if you look at it through the larger
lens of history,
this is not a new story.